[Musique]
ça peut toucher convenait à la ruine
nico but va sauver 100 potage et comment
tu veux remporter une jolie cagnotte
pour ton école inscris-toi hominick aux
abattoirs
[Musique]
mais qui chante comme une casserole mais
je triche comme est roi je te donne mes
notes je te je sais pas quand il
maîtrise le roi de la triche est de
retour
est il apte à concurrence voilà l'on
pourrait la capitale de quel pays la
malaisie pour sauver saint potache ils
vont devoir faire équipe
ça va être la triche du siècle
bienvenue dans le temple de la triche on
triche comme ça ça n'arrive qu'une seule
fois dans la vie elle ne veut pas
entendre une mouche voler le roi de la
triche est de retour et il faut 7 6 x 52
7 x 7 49 et il est la concurrence
qu'elle et l'imparfait du subjonctif du
verbe avoir que juste que tu ce qui lui
ont dit qu'ils y travaillent sont allés
pourquoi vous portez un col roulé par ce
beau temps j'en étais sûr changera
jamais sa mission sera pourtant chez
condamné alors oui
stern a sauvé son école j'ai une immense
nouvelle pour toi tu veux remporter une
jolie cagnotte pour ton école
ce soir
inscris toi au mini conservatoire mais
chante comme une casserole mais je
triche comme un roi ça va être la triche
du siet bienvenue dans le temple de la
crise à partir de maintenant on est les
frérots de la cia
je te donne mes notes je te donne mes
mots restaurer ducobu change d'école
ducobu va sauver saint potache votre
visite un génie en crever nombreux
champs
ce n'est pas maître gims faute avouée
qu'il a un joli petit brin de voix à mon
pote
vous devez le chouchouter le foot à
l'humiliation
je sais pas comment il fait il triche
ducobu toi enfin si je sens quelques
salmigondis je serai impitoyable
implacable fait rare tout en restant
dans les limites des lois de la
république le 5 février au cinéma